I welcome to this video playing j'adoube
first yeah makes sense get your pieces
nicely positioned before you start in
knowledge chest you need to do that of
course you don't need to do that of
course i had gettin the groom found yeah
damn let's let's play this again yeah
cautious someone might play someone
might play on it should be six or
something on a six i have seen the
smooth queen a four maybe this is rather
try it prevents be five i can just take
it out to be 5 okay at least he's
irritated I that does not know exactly
what to do good sign yeah all this is
still a very normal looking reply should
you take on not interesting may be
defined d5 is certainly more vicious or
there may be maybe someone business
taking it and trying to to keep the part
is also ambitious play I can I take it
97 no the question is is Bishop b3 a
move on yeah there might be no g-form
that's not good if I go e5 or to see
playing actually
95 queen aged three years a double
attack young he's still playing it cool
yeah well why on earth do you even
calculate stuff people just ignore what
you do like this 7am he's got my g7 ok
now this might be a weakness here
shouldn't dream maybe I should really
really just cover it this pawn 95 isn't
this something Bonnie seven I don't know
check take first think later I think
really this is the supplies iam the
thing is it's still some compensation
unfortunately I mean he blundered this
but it's still compensation a bit hm if
I allow him to go Bishop d7 I mean this
night might not get back so i probably
need to take and now this is the problem
I mean simply not well developed move
like night a4 might be coming getting at
the beep on I wonder about Bishop c4
come on ready to just take this is
playing so quickly yeah
the check here maybe his placing his
hope no I would have played King did to
anyway so like that Roxy too okay at
least the bishop is not not in play yeah
I kept the porn but his immediate play
get got him to some time advantage rook
be to coming that's a passive and
grilling
I want I want to play actively work the
1d seven stuff like that maybe Luke a
five wasn't in great I think this is
better plane playing here and not
defending stuff what now 92 and we had
eaten the other night is so passively
placed and the bishop it's also not
great
I don't really see how to activate it I
mean 94s not even possible nitey for now
maybe 94 I really hope to punish this
play I mean it's just dashing out
instant moves we are punishing it you
had blundering my book a little less
frustrating I mean this guy is just
playing instant moves with no no idea
whatsoever and I blundering stuff
this is endgame I don't know how would
you see how do you win now I was
interesting to see credible check check
check I'm winning I don't believe it
black resigns Wow I mean sometimes it's
really amazing what happens and this is
really really great I mean I'm just
telling you I like to punish what this
guy is playing and then a blundering
just this exchange Wow yeah very very
very difficult again very difficult
position it's just so frustrating you
think and think and they just play move
move move and it's a it's not that bad I
mean heart out this is really hard to
play this position he's got the active
rooks yeah I've got this is somewhat
weak and I mean this this does not look
great on g7 but my pieces are also not
good it's a it's a very tricky position
you can really invest some time and I
think it's always frustrating if those
instant moves are even okay yeah no he
needs to go back and very very hard to
activate him and we had try it with
would have three this is at least
constructive plan this is good I mean
this is good well played i cannot go e6
here and i bear must played it this one
probably and then 94
something like that should probably end
in a draw of course this justice just I
could have played a seven year but I was
22 shocked that was too shocked this is
even notice kisses and so clear actually
I approved yet my needs to play this one
I cool check I really should have
thought here again yeah this is still a
game cool yeah I was too frustrated this
is complete completely unnecessary of
course I mean it's it might win but it's
not necessary now work before is this is
that it was completely unnecessary to go
for that and this is I mean I don't know
why you give up the porn maybe it was a
mouse slip check yeah after that check
it's nothing bad happened chatter he
needs two loops check check he needs to
go back of course different if I now
take I don't have this queen of a trick
Wow hair-raising oh but they weren't at
least thanks for watching